[Applause]
they are called terrorists for
destroying the property or trying to
take over america this is another
conversation that happened a lot is like
why are they terrorists but
the people that were burning down cities
uh as
part of the blm protests why were they
not considered terrorists that was
another conversation
yeah so i think terrorists to be a
terrorist it has to be like destruction
with a political aim basically right
like if you have
some sort of like political agenda and
you start doing the violent [ __ ]
you can be classified as a terrorist
yeah that is the textbook definition of
terrorism right it's violence with
political aim
right so i think like the like people
that stormed the capital they had a
political aim
and they were violent yeah so that would
classify yeah i also think yeah
blm you if if you have a political aim i
would say right yeah
specifically that we all agree with
right we want
equality but it is it's
not just any political aim this specific
political aim was we are trying to
stop the government from moving forward
the way it's moving forward and change
the way it moves forward right through
our
idea of what democracy is that's what a
lot of terrorists are doing so this is
your idea of democracy is different than
ours and they think
they're wrong but so are the people who
storm the capital right now to me that's
terrorism
i think guess where it gets hazy is that
you have to look at the specific
like behavior in the action itself so
like when it comes to like storming the
capital it seems like oh yeah of course
that's wrong but
there are certain situations where that
behavior is justified so like if the
you know if let's say trump does another
four years and then at the end of his
eight year
two term tenure he says i'm not leaving
it would be
i think at the obligation of citizens to
go in and say nah you're out
exactly so the behavior itself is
condemnable
in this context because we don't feel
like it's actually justified
what's justified or not exactly the
winner does so like let's say
let's say these that people actually
like stormed and overthrew the whole
[ __ ] and then they
won and they were actually able to
somehow they're heroes they're not
treason
they rewrite the history and they go
yeah the election was stolen we want it
back they tell their kids blah blah and
then that's how history gets worked like
when bolsheviks took over that [ __ ]
there was like so few of them
like any insurrection or coup or
revolution starts with like this
american revolution
the american revolution was not so
wildly supported by every single
american there were a lot of americans
that were businessmen a lot of americans
were just on the british side
that was just what they thought was the
right thing to do even during the
revolution not everybody was supportive
of it
right so yeah they won and then
everybody was like oh i guess
they're heroes and uh we got to go along
with that yeah so destroying police cars
like this summer
in any situation i'm like yeah that's
wrong unless you believe that the social
contract has been broken so if you
believe that cops are not upholding
their duty to protect citizens
then you have an obligation to then
rebel against the state well then to
your point to that point that's what
these people believe
exactly so which is why i have empathy
for like the guy that's like trapped in
some rural area that's plugged into like
newsmax that's getting like all this
information truly believing that all
this [ __ ] was stolen clarify for any
crazy people listening that doesn't mean
you support what they did no of course
understand how they got i'm sympathetic
and i'm like oh wow you got conned
you know i mean you thought that you
were inside the con but actually you
were the mark the whole time like you
got duped so i have sympathy for those
people i think they should still be
punished for what they did yes but i
think their behavior is very different
than someone that went in like
okay i know that this election was valid
that the voter fraud didn't like
substantiate actual like uh
like electoral turnover and i'm just
gonna go in there to [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
because i want violence and whatever
like those people i think
i agree with you i have sympathy to a
certain extent like i have sympathy for
belief but i don't have sympathy for
action
yeah of course so it's like what you
could believe the crazy [ __ ] and i could
feel bad for you like i could see
somebody get radicalized
and like think these horrible things and
then i start going ah man it sucks that
you were
tricked into believing these things and
and i hate that you
live in this vacuum that allows only one
belief system that you have to kind of
believe in order to exist within your
tiny life you don't believe it
wholeheartedly you're
a separatist or crazy or whatever but
don't ostracize you completely but then
you kill a cop but killing somebody
based on those beliefs is where i don't
have any 100 percent which is why when
it comes to like
they need to interrupt but like because
there is a social contract that exists
even within those beliefs
the cops handle justice when you take
justice in your own hands you are
breaking that contract
and you made with the car i think you
can also have empathy and still think
that sucks
i see how you got there you should still
be punished within the harshest measures
100 percent yeah like it's the starting
measures is the punishment for treason
is you die well it depends on if these
people were
like like convicted of treason or like
whatever their actual conviction is
depending on what they thought they were
doing at the time exactly so that's the
other thing that goes on with it i don't
think everybody there thought that they
were going to overthrow the government
and i think that that's
clear by the people taking selfies
inside right like
when they actually got in the position i
think a lot of them were like oh yeah we
never really knew what we were going to
do here
we were just essentially blowing off
steam because we're upset that trump
some people knew what they were doing
and those people you could argue could
be punished but how do you decipher who
those people are and i think you just
have a case-by-case trial for all the
people that are
gonna be alive now here's the question i
don't know now here's the question
should the same energy be kept with the
people at blm
for example the majority the vast
majority of the people there at these
protests
were going we need to make sure that we
just protest for what we believe in
and we keep it safe and we don't destroy
any property and
and we don't do anything that could take
away from this movement and then there
was a couple people there
that violently looted killed somebody
blew up buildings
caused massive property damage that
destroy businesses
what should happen to those people is
what those people did
treasonous per se they should have a
fair and just trial based off of the
specific circumstances
i guess my point is like the the
severity of treason in our eyes
right uh brings us to a point of death
right like if you commit treason you die
right it's
really really really severe it's the
most severe nothing is more severe than
death
so can i apply that
to the people at the capitol and can i
also apply that to someone in minnesota
that lit
a police station on fire am i okay with
them dying
because of that that's where it gets
strange when i say harsh as possible i'm
not a death penalty person in general
so i would remove that from my own but i
see what i said so i don't agree that
they should all be put to death yeah but
25 years 30 years i agree with
punishment yeah i agree with punishment
for crime we're all on the same page but
like
for whatever you know treason the
punishment is death so it's just like
okay that's okay go well uh a couple
things yeah it's
hard for me to separate if you have
empathy for
them being tricked and actually
believing
that they're doing something to save
america then
how can you not have empathy for them
protecting america and taking the
actions that they have like how do you
separate the two because if they
truly believe that they're doing
something great like how
the american revolution we believe like
yeah we're fighting against british we
were being treasonous
at the time to the government that was
controlling us
so so you have to have empathy for the
action because they think they're
doing the right thing the empathy for
their actions for their action how do
you separate people
it depends on what the action is i think
if the action is killing people then
that pretty much in all circumstances
unless it's self-defense that's right
that's
the killing of the cop because not all
of them were doing that let's just say
uh storming the capital right so like if
it's like destruction all the other [ __ ]
like they should definitely be
still punished for what they did because
the action itself is illegal
so here's the thing but i understand
from a personal level i get how they get
there
and that's what you're trying to say you
have empathy for the action and that's
what we were saying last week or at
least it was on the uh maybe it was on
the patreon
no i think it was on the patreon the
idea is if you truly believe
that like you were stopping the most
vile human beings on the planet yeah
from
corrupting a country that you love it is
heroic
to put your life on the line to do that
yeah so you have empathy for that if
that's what they believe
that being said who is the arbiter of
that truth
unfortunately it's the victor and they
lost right so their truth
and literally is now false rudy giuliani
before like the day of on the steps he
goes
all right if we're wrong we're going to
get made fools of if we're right
a lot of people are going to jail so
let's have a trial by combat
yeah literally word for word like what
he says like the the day of so like
so these people are sitting there and
they're like okay we're trusting the
plan we believe rudy giuliani like he's
never lied to us he's always been honest
we got to trust him
then he says this you um all right [ __ ]
it that's what i would say to you i can
have empathy
for the motive to the point even when
okay i can have empathy for how you did
that action
but you still got to be punished you
broke the law yeah a kid that sells
drugs to feed his family
hey man i have empathy for that motive
you still sold drugs and [ __ ] up a lot
of people yeah
you get your punishment even though if
even the thing that you wanted might be
good
yeah you break a window on accident if
you don't want to move down south
because
you know it might be hypocritical at the
same time
for a better life and we all have a
better life everybody else
yes yes everybody also your family
everybody's gone like blm welcome with
the storm in the capital and i think i
don't know if you can really consider
blm treasonous because they're not they
weren't trying to overthrow the
government
correct so i think that's the separate
discrepancy that i would make as well
because blm wasn't saying hey we want to
stop america from existing
and we want to have a different way of
america my
understanding of blm the protest was
we want the rights we're supposed to
have yo america is delicious
we would like to be lit too yeah so
yeah it's the opposite of treason so i
don't get how you label them
trees in this group no i don't know
where they can be destructive
yeah riots all that [ __ ] yes that's
where these twitter conversations i
haven't people
yeah it's hard to have nuance in 140
characters or whatever no no but it's
it's not like uh they're essentially
being labeled treasonous what i think is
is the
the distinguishing factor with the
capital situation is treason right
because that means death
right right and people are comparing
these two and i don't think they're
comparable i guess for that reason is
most eloquently said al is it they're
not asking for something
to change in america that wasn't
promised boom
as far as i can understand they want the
promises to be kept for them as well now
we can go into the blm organization we
did it in the netflix special where the
organization itself
wanted maybe a more socialist or some
by people might even say marxist
approach to america yeah
you could say that is changing america
in a way that maybe most americans might
not want to support
but like we said in the special the
marching itself yes
people out in the street people on the
street who don't know who the [ __ ] karl
marx is
yeah yeah we're just like yo can black
people not get chopped by cops
if they don't do nothing bad is that
cool right well yeah
now people at the capitol though they
thought oh the election were promised
fair elections and then we didn't get a
fair election so now we gotta go get a
fair election yeah
that's i understand again i have empathy
for the motive did they want it did they
want a fair election or did they want
their guy to win the matter
i think most of them wanted the guy to
win but i think some got duped i think
they convinced themselves
on some level whether consciously or
subconscious
whatever subconsciously this was rigged
and stolen from us and they
you believe the truth that's convenient
because that's the only way you can
rationalize one and you've got to win
yes you
tell the stories and the narratives that
are convenient for what you want that's
a logic
to make to justify your emotions yeah so
now can we
uh say one more thing and maybe this is
crazy but why it's different to me
right because it's warmer down there we
got a full-size
nba gym is that where you're going to go
with this things are open yeah you can
go play basketball we can have fun
little hijinks yeah you can do
even busters we can go to dave buster's
we can play pranks
oh and if you would like to make up for
that uh the minute anything we have
outside
yeah there is an [ __ ] that reached
out to us he's willing to make us a
custom
arcane machine that has like over
thousands of games and it's a regulatory
size that's what we can put me in them
i'll take it out of the patreon
here's the thing here's the thing about
that yeah i don't like it when there's
multiple games in the one thing
um i'm stupid yes because now you could
put
all those games on your phone that's why
we don't reply to your text messages
but i don't like it i don't like it come
on
yeah it feels like a shortcut a little
bit i actually get what you're saying
you like the game i want if i'm gonna
get an arcade game
i want the nostalgia yeah you want
terminator with the guns with the one
game
i want the joystick to look like it
sunset rider and street fighter
all i want like come on no no no just
get on your pc
yeah put my gift to you guys you will
pay for this machine
twenty-five hundred to you
i'm starting to think
he probably got new sneakers news
you